joining us now with a full report is
someone who's actually visited the
Border many times Fox News contributor
Sarah Carter joins us live in
Brownsville Texas Sarah thanks for all
the work you're doing what are you
seeing
oh I think yeah thank you Pete thank you
I'm here in Brownsville as you see
behind me is the Port of Entry it
buttresses Matamoros Mexico and I gotta
tell you Pete right across the border
just several miles from us is an open
Park where over 8 000 that's over 8 000
just here in Matamoros people are
waiting to come across the border these
are people that have been told by the
Smugglers that title 42 is going to end
on Wednesday right now chief justice
Roberts did have a stay to uphold title
42 they are going to uphold that until
tomorrow at 5 00 PM when they're going
to give the Department of Justice an
opportunity to respond that is the Biden
Administration is going to respond as to
why we don't need Title 42. I can tell
you this federal law enforcement
officials as well as members of the
border patrol are very very concerned
they're already seeing those swells
those migrant swells coming in not just
in El Paso but here in Brownsville in
McAllen Texas and across the border in
Arizona and California as well and they
say with the removal of title 42 they
expect up to 18
000 people a day but that's only because
of the removal of title 42. they're
still expecting those swells to come in
I spoke today to uh vice president of
the national border patrol Council here
in the Rio Grande Valley Chris Cabrera
and he said those people that are coming
in right now aren't just the people that
are being held back from title 42 but
these are people that aren't being held
back from Child Support 42 people from
Venezuela people from Cuba people from
Afghanistan people from Pakistan I want
you to take a listen to what he had to
say
I mean based on what you've seen the
last few years
how much of a difference is it going to
be to remove title 42 I mean if if we're
already seeing these numbers is it just
is it just going to be more of the same
or far worse it's going to be far worse
right now we have certain people that we
can send back uh under title 42 but
there are certain countries that can't
be sent back under title 42 and that's
what we're seeing now mostly uh
venezuelan's nicaraguans Cubans they're
coming across in huge numbers and
there's nothing we can do about it now
uh it's for everyone else everyone else
is not going to be affected by so the 50
000 or so that are supposedly in Mexico
right now waiting to cross that's it
yeah and then on top of that you have uh
the others that are just now getting the
memo that are going to mobilize and come
over from all over the world not just
from Central and South America we have a
lot coming from uh European countries
aging countries you name it they're
they're coming already and they're going
to continue to come
well P despite the fact that judges have
upheld were made in Mexico and title 42
border patrol agents say if the Biden
Administration doesn't uphold the law
then the law will not be upheld it won't
even matter the people will just keep
pouring in Pete
hmm Sarah hold on real quick so does
that so the world is coming
does that just mean we're going to
process them faster and release them
more people in Mass so so the process
really doesn't change it's just a a
bigger Mass release of people none of
which gets sent back
that's absolutely correct right now what
we're seeing is a number of people
they'll talk about apprehensions at the
border well then the majority of those
apprehensions are released within a day
or two we don't even have the facilities
here in Texas and this is according to
the governor this is according to Texas
DPS this is according to border patrol
as well as Immigration and Customs
Enforcement to hold all the people that
are coming across so yes what you're
saying is correct Pete they're just
brand them in they're processing them
they can't even do full background
checks on many of these people they're
just being released into the United
States right before I got on with you
Pete a young family walked by me and
they had a baby and you can see that
they had just come across the border and
they were asking for directions to the
bus station they had a little child with
them people are sleeping in the streets
here in Texas and you know they don't
just stay here in Texas they end up all
across the United States and I think
worst of all Before I Let You Go is the
fact that many times the cartels are
moving a lot of people big large groups
and while they're doing that they're
moving Fentanyl and other narcotics into
the United States and there's nobody
there to stop them this is a very
dangerous crisis for our nation we don't
know who's coming in and it's affecting
everyone not just the people crossing
the border but our children and the
people in the United States as well
and as we spend all those man hours
processing hordes of people those are
agents that are not working the line as
people with even more nefarious
intentions are choosing different routes
Sarah Carter thank you so much for your
reporting we appreciate it hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else